[Music]
dark one episode two curse of the
wendi-go written by david ramana my
hands were still bloody that's the
craziest thing you could still see the
swelling around the knuckles the dirt in
the fingernails the specks of blood that
ran up my wrists I'd wash them I swear I
did I'd wash them so much they started
calling me Lady Macbeth funny there I
sat in the same rickety chair with the
flickering fluorescent light boxed in by
walls as emotionless as concrete at
least it had a bit of colour err and
their baby blue walls that I heard them
say induced peace and relaxation guess
it was hard to appreciate it when the
metal from the CAF's dug into my skin
there was a dirty mirror ahead of me
that covered most of the wall spotted
with white and grey dots like that of an
unclean bathroom mirror spattered with
ricocheting specks of toothpaste staring
at myself it would have come as no
surprise that I didn't recognize the man
staring back at me bastard had shaved my
head and now stubbly growth dominated
what was once a beautiful set of hair at
least that's what she told me I looked
down at my hands again but I always did
whenever I thought of her my eyes were
sunken not uncommon in my line of work
though burdened of the thickest of bags
like dirty rainwater in a cloud my mouth
was bleeding from where I chewed my lip
again and my nose crooked from to be
honest I don't even remember how that
happened but I remember what I remember
and I suppose that's hell enough that
was when the door opened and he proud in
with a calm yet poised expression on his
face
i clenched my fist and started to replay
the last six months the way I always did
as he stood there impassively the hint
of hatred in his eyes I called him the
tormentor for what type of man would
make me relive this over and over again
from the top
mist the Mason he prompted me of the
clicking of his pen ready to scribble
down everything I had already told him
sometimes I messed with him change the
details slightly and gave him nuggets of
fresh insight in the end though the
outcome was always the same my name is
chase Mason I told the Tormentor in the
crocus of voices I am a wildlife
biologist it all started
six months ago with the usual beeping of
the alarm clock my hand found the snooze
button before my eyes cracks open and
there I was staring at the blurry red
figures reading 6 a.m. a slender set of
fingers found their way through my hair
training down the back of my neck and
then back up again I love this hair a
dove whispered if I knew what the next
few days would have looked like I'd have
laid there forever but we all look back
on things we would have done differently
don't we I forced myself up out of bed
her hand falling weakly down my back and
onto the mattress don't ask me why I was
so cold and I'm responsive maybe it was
the cold mornings in the early starts
making me cranky er and far more
irritable than usual maybe it was the
unpacked boxes that still towered about
our bedroom or the fact that we still
hadn't found a school for our boy Marcus
maybe I just wasn't in love anymore as
foolish as that now seems I glanced over
my shoulder at a door and smiled it was
the least I could do she glanced up with
her subtle green eyes and smiled wanly
knowing full well that I was thinking
about nothing but work the stress of
leaving our dreamy life behind in
Florida to the Algonquin reserves of
Canada had definitely taken its toll on
both of us but I couldn't say I wasn't
excited as I stood up from the bed and
meandered my way into the bathroom I
mean there were things that I still
missed I missed the energy of our own
home the backyard Paul and especially
the weather but life had become stale it
was Groundhog Day that month however I
was able to break the cycle when I'd
been called in by the local authority to
conduct research on a series of vicious
attacks on the local wildlife there had
also been three known fatalities and a
brutal attack on a young girl who
described the so-called creature in
question as a Wolfman
I remembered brushing my teeth in
grinning at the absurdity of it all a
[ __ ] wolf man people certainly had
the wackiest theories for things they
couldn't explain morning Aaron passed me
in the corridors I left the bathroom
eyes bloodshot from crying no doubt with
a coffee in one hand and a cigarette in
the other it seemed like he never went
anywhere without one or the other
morning I greeted him as he strode his
way over to the balcony he was wrapped
up in his black cotton robe toes exposed
on his velvet sandals but somehow he
didn't feel the cold as he stepped out
onto the deck letting in a rush of
wintry air what are we gonna do with him
ada appeared behind me with a sigh he's
your brother
I might have said a little too
accusatory like he was a burden to be
honest I'd grown quite sick of seeing
him mope around he'd been with us for
two months back in Florida after his
wife divorced him and since then he quit
his psychotherapy job and ironically he
looked like he could do with some help
himself well I couldn't just leave him
on the street ADA said pouring herself a
coffee he had to come with us
did he I thought to say if I'm not
around to keep an eye on him I'm worried
what he might do
I watched Aaron for a moment just
sipping on his coffee over the wooden
rail of the deck pondering on the
dawning sunlight transfix on it almost
like he could hear it talking to him the
poor guy had been taken to the cleaners
by his ex-wife's lawyers and now now he
was just a shell barely alive at all
maybe he can help with the unpacking I
glanced around the dining area where we
put most of the boxes as well as along
the kitchen counters which were lined of
cups and plates still wrapped in
newspaper
that's all you're interested in isn't it
ada said in a tone that warranted me
reaching for the car keys and driving
off to work you just want to move on as
quickly as possible
don't you is there much sense in
dwelling on the past I calmly told her
she folded her arms and that infuriating
way and the subtle vein on her forehead
that I pretended her love began to throb
I miss our home chase you mean you miss
be no good by the neighbors when your
poor side I thought to say but knew that
it would probably see the coffee machine
lobbed at my head it wouldn't have been
the first time I miss home too but this
is a big opportunity for me to get my
name out there your name is out there
she strode over and placed her hands on
my shoulders you're one of the most
renowned wildlife experts in the country
and the second most handsome - who's the
first I inquired bear grylls she told me
I don't really think that he's much I
didn't get a chance to finish my
sentence
they came a scream from the next room
though not just any scream it was a
violent wailing a horrible distressing
sound that had me springing into action
Marcus I thrust opened the door and
there he was in bed mouth wide as he
screamed at the window thrust in his
arms like a mad composure I froze I'd
seen his outbursts before and while I
was never great at defusing him I had
learned how to coax him back to reality
my son was openly crying red in the face
and clearly distraught at something at
the window but all I could do was stand
there in the doorway watching him lose
his [ __ ] as a smell of urine became ever
more apparent Marcus a debauch passed me
and threw her arms around him he was
inconsolable though much as he usually
was his gaunt cheeks were shining with
tears his one big eye twitching and his
smaller one dead and still caveman-like
escaped his trembling lips webs of
saliva sprayed into my wife's hair it
wasn't the first time I'd been disgusted
at the sight of my hideous deformed
child you had a nightmare Marcus ADA
whisper to him as he sat there grunting
and groaning it was times like this I
did truly admire her she'd never looked
at him funny never flinched at the sight
of him and shown him nothing but the
goodness of her heart me I stared into
the vacant eyes of that boy and would
have soon and gone out onto the deck and
conversed of Aaron a window
Marcus continued to point Linda go and
check the window either hissed at me
before cooing by Marcus's ear daddy's
going to investigate sweetie he'll show
you there's nothing there there isn't
anything there I said adamantly go and
check she admonished me I signed but
complied anyway I lifted the latch on
the misty window and pushed it open only
to be met by that chilly Canadian air I
couldn't say that it wasn't refreshing
though as the smells of the trees
congregated around my nose bringing with
it the sense of adventure it was almost
enough to get me to stop thinking about
my 16 year old son who ADA was now
helping out a bed nothing here I said of
disdain you see Marcus ADA said it was
all a dream the same dream you've been
having since we got here I thought to
add but I was sure the boy didn't
understand me I was sure he didn't
understand a damn thing I went to close
the window but of my shock there seemed
to be two prints in the mud below I'd
seen enough wolf prints to know when I
saw them but these are much bigger
looking and deeper too implying whatever
left them must be quite heavy it wasn't
uncommon to see wolves in the area
living this close to the woods and all
but something about those prints had me
weirdly captivated what is it
ADA asked
is there something out there no I said
and pulled the window shut it's nothing
the last thing I wanted was for ADA to
start thinking that a wolf for stalking
our child or even that a wolf had been
that close to the window in the first
place you go on to work ADA told me
I'll get markers cleaned up and see what
we can do about getting him into a
school maybe mommy's little angel can
help me unpack some of these boxes -
Marcus grinned at that and ADA grin
right back at him like she saw a normal
16 year old boy and not the bulbous
creature with a wet patch down his
trouser leg I'll see you tonight I
kissed ADA in the forehead and I suppose
a proper dad would have kissed his son -
but I didn't have a proper son did I as
selfish and inhumane as that may sound I
patted Marcus on the head the way a man
might have patted a diseased dog and
hurried my way out of the house I'd made
it halfway down the long and daunting
road towards the inner town where my new
office was when I received the phone
call I placed my cellphone on the
dashboard half expecting to see ADA
stays flashing on the screen reminding
me to buy groceries instead it was a
gray silhouette and the name Hoff before
I could even say hello
my boss his brash tone rocketed out of
the phone and blasted away whatever
sleep was still left in my eyes trace
where in the blazes are you he sounded
disgruntled not to say he ever sounded
like anything else to be fair I don't
own the man for a few weeks but already
I tossed him out as a panicking meatball
of Rage I'm driving in I told him and
took a moment to glance at the time
I certainly wasn't running late driving
in where he barked and I could hear the
rustling of a bag of chips I'm going to
the office are you daft didn't you see
the news this morning
no I didn't have time I said thinking
about Marcus and what he might have seen
we'll get down to the resolve pronto
there's been another attack of this
rogue creature and the police want you
to take a look at the wounds the reserve
I said with reluctance I never went in
for that superstitious nonsense but
there was something about that stretch
of land they gave me the creeps
maybe it was a stories of witch doctors
and shamans performing dark rituals on
cursed land I don't know whatever it was
it made me feel uneasy
don't get all wimpy on me now boy
nothing here but fresh animal carcass
and a few corpses half said as cheerily
as I'd ever heard him wait corpses I
almost slam my foot on the brakes yes
corpses looks like our creature has
gotten a taste for human flesh see you
in a bit wait half hung up and I was
left to drive the rest of the way in
silence I slowed as I turned into the
reserve for a convoy of police cars or
scattered here and there on the
grassland a yellow sedan stood out like
a sore thumb and as I drew closer I
could see Hopf pacing up and down his
stout arms flying back and forth as he
gave directions to the biology crew what
had me straightening in the car was the
sight of the natives at least a dozen of
them dressed in furs and ceremonial garb
lingering around the cordoned off square
daringly edging against the yellow
police tape
they had no expressions just the same
steely glare as they pondered on the
body scattered in the grass why their
presence made me so nervous
I couldn't quite say you sure took your
time getting here
half marched his way towards me as I
exited the car his bushy moustache was
shifting left and right and the redness
around his cheeks made them seem like
they were swelling up half wasn't a man
of much height but what the short fellow
lacked in torn us he made up foreign
Gordy bellows he was the type of man
you'd hear long before you actually saw
him what are we looking at here I
ignored his little jab mincing words of
half was a quick way to the unemployment
line or so I'd heard death and a lot of
it Hoff swung his fat arm across the
open field forensics in their white
suits were mulling over the human bodies
and a few of my colleagues had puzzled
over the remains of what looked like
bloody flesh and fur the police are
mostly smoking either that or staring
off against the natives who didn't look
like they'd be leaving at anytime soon
what's their deal
I asked off as he led me over to the
first carcass hell if I know off
shrugged bunch of superstitious pansies
warning us about this being sacred
ground and it's dangerous you think they
have a point
I asked off not that I was into all this
superstitious nonsense but merely to
amuse myself at his reaction of course
they bloody don't he grunted been a
police state put an end to their
trifling thank goodness I mused before
exchanging a look of one of the natives
whose eyes were filled of dread Hoff
stood over my shoulder breathing down my
neck like a damn [ __ ] even as I touched
the deep chasm like holes that have been
torn into the hide of what may have been
a deer Hoff stood there with his hands
on his hips waiting for me to announce
the identity of the animal who had done
this but the holes in the day were just
the beginning its neck had been slashed
and blood had a frozen around the gash
one of its antlers had most certainly
been chewed the other bent back was in
an unnatural
fashioned it retained three of its four
legs while the fourth was severed and
lay nearby with bones shooting out its
flesh had been mostly devoured though
the cuts were not precise or calculated
meaning that something had feasted on
the animal as opposed to skinning it it
hauled out a human attack but what
animal would savagely brutalize another
like this they say it was wolves half
had a tendency of answering questions I
was thinking wolves hunt in packs I said
as I examine the teeth marks on the deer
this seems like a single creature did
this and if it was a wolf it wouldn't
have the strength to just rip off a
deers leg like this so what does a fast
a bear I guessed but there aren't many
sightings of bears in this area and from
what I know about bears they wouldn't
brutalize an animal in this way do you
think it might have been human then
Houghton's sound convinced I pointed at
the teeth marks on the deer you ever
seen a human of a set of teeth like that
Hoss scratched his moustache Only Knows
vampire movies what's it called Twilight
you watch Twilight I looked up of a
laughs I have daughters chase it's
either watch the damn movie of them or
talk about college majors brutal you're
lucky you have a son chase off muttered
and marched off to another carcass yeah
real lucky I thought to say the more I
saw of the carcasses the less everything
made sense to tell you the truth I had
never seen anything like this
eyes of hares had been sucked out as
clips off feet were missing and tails
seemingly severed it wasn't the best
smelling place either as you could
imagine I couldn't count how many times
I'd walked in [ __ ] damn near slipping in
strewn guts that I wasn't even sure or
exclusively animal there were two more
deers even more compelling than the
first one who'd been sawn in half and
left to rot and another that had its
head completely removed
we searched for a while but we could
never find it what on earth could have
done this I found myself asking I
thought I'd be able to piece some clues
together if I was allowed to examine the
human corpses but the police weren't too
keen on having anyone other than the
friends that crew near the bodies pretty
soon they'd set up tents around each
victim and had left us wildlife experts
stumbling in the muck trying to figure
this all out I'm stumped off through his
hands by his side 25 years I've been
doing this and never have I seen
something like this before I'd only been
doing this for the better part of 10
years but still nothing could have
prepared me for the bloodbath we know
sat in I was about to get up and leave
having examined everything at least a
dozen times we had our samples in our
data now all we had to do was run it
through the lab and see if they could
identify this creature or at least prove
that it may have been a human but
something caught my eye
there in the dirt was a sunken paw print
a paw print net bore an eerie
resemblance to the one I'd seen outside
of Marcus's window hey Hoff I called him
over what do you make of this Hoff took
his glasses off and leaned closer to the
print so close that I was scared he
might have gone tumbling over four toes
four spikes and a triangular shape to
bump off nodded to himself that's a wolf
print all right but it's deep must have
been a big bugger certainly bigger than
normal
funny how its prints don't lead anywhere
I noted there's just one print
that's not normal because it is no paw
print a deep voice Rumble above me in
half Hoff damn near slipped on his ass
as he scrambled to his feet and I fared
little better sitting there frozen as a
native towered over me what do you mean
it's no paw print off challenged him and
you lot shouldn't be here anyway go on
scram you're hindering our investigation
it is no paw print
the native said again with a stone
conviction eyeing us both with a certain
loathing in his eyes at least it does
not belong to a wolf nor any animal you
can conceive so let me guess Hof snorted
it's Bigfoot is it tell me it's Bigfoot
I dare you
Bigfoot is my cousin the native replied
without hesitation and pointed at a
smaller man standing as close to the
forensic tents as he could get Bigfoot
did not do this Christ help me Hof
rolled his eyes so what did do this then
I asked as I was all out of ideas the
native didn't look at me right away hey
strong jaunt witched a moment like he
was wrestling with the idea it is a
beast that roams the land taking meat
from the bones of all it finds does it
have a name I asked partly intrigued and
partly out of sheer amusement the native
looked at me then really looked at me
like he was staring into the deeper
parts of my soul and didn't quite like
what he saw I couldn't blame him I
wasn't a huge fan of those parts either
it is not my place to say the native
declared funny that I said and earned
myself a hint of a scowl you will both
do well to leave this place the native
bowed his head The Hunger of the beast
will not stay sated for long well bear
that in mind half said of a smirk the
native didn't look too convinced guess I
better start leaving some snacks out for
this beast at my house then I laughed
the native gave me a sideways glance
what do you mean I grinned and pointed
at the footprint the founder print just
like that outside my son's window this
morning
seems like this beast of yours is
covering a lot of ground
I'll found that pretty funny laughing to
himself but the native looked over
positive
horrifying you must be careful friend
the native told me in a tone that
implied we definitely were not friends
the Beast does not tread without reason
you should leave this place while you
can take your son and your wife and all
those you hold dear and leave
I do miss Florida I look to Hoff who
burst out laughing again you have been
warned
friend he told me before tracking his
way back to the carcasses and
disappearing into the wood
what a [ __ ] loon off scratched his
hand for once we agreed
the Tormentor slammed his fist on the
table a surge of redness palpitating
around his wrist from where he squeezed
and just like that I was back in the
room my own personal hell where I was
neither dead nor alive with nothing but
the chair the desk in the blue walls for
company oh and the cast how could I
forget about the steel chafing into my
flesh you're really trying my patience
mr. Mason he said of that controlled
sort of seething like a savage wild man
who had learned composure but hadn't
quite gotten it down yet I anticipated
the day it hit me but it never came I
wanted him to hit me I heard that if he
did they'd have to bring in someone else
you wanted the story I'm telling you the
story again I said as calmly as I could
he'd never have guessed I wanted to
snatch the pen out of his hand and jam
it into his eye socket where are your
wife and son mr. Mason he prompted me I
took a moment to think about it
I wondered what would have happened if I
just made something up told him they
were in Mexico eating enchiladas just to
see what would happen in the end though
I didn't have the energy to formulate
anything concrete and so I gave him the
answer he'd come to expect you really
are a broken record aren't you mr. Mason
the Tormentor signed as he pulled a
tissue out of his blazer pocket to dab
his nose who's broken I asked him the
record or the one playing the record
he didn't like that the creases on his
forehead tightened and a vein I hadn't
quite noticed before made a subtle
appearance it reminded me of ADA the
Tormentor clicked his pen then was
scribbling something down but halfway
through he looked up at me and gave me a
vengeful glare suddenly I thought maybe
I was the one getting the pen through
the eye continue your story mr. Mason he
told me so I did
I remembered stirring in my sleep that
night on the account of Marcus's
screaming the boy was like a smoke
detector shrill enough they probably
heard him in the surrounding forest
either groan something out the side of
her mouth something about it being my
turn and I had half a mind to tell her
that it was her turn to get a damn job
but I didn't it wouldn't have been fair
if she wasn't here to look over Marcus
then who would Aaron I wouldn't trust
that depressed alcoholic [ __ ] to look
after a dog
he'd probably talk it into suicide I
kicked the covers off a numbered my way
across the room out the door and onto
the landing that was when I heard it how
I heard anything over the sound of
Marcus's wailing I'll never know but it
was there it was a throaty growl so deep
and intense that I knew my son couldn't
have made that sound
it hardly sounded like anything from
this world and I had heard the growl of
almost every animal alive I hurried to
the door my heart was thumping in my
chest maybe I did love the boy after all
because I could think of nothing but
storming in there and facing whatever
was present the door was stuck I turned
the hand to a dozen times but it
wouldn't budge
I found myself shouldering the door
throwing my own weight against it Marcus
I shouted before hammering the door open
the door I tried again desperately
ramming my shoulder against the wood to
break the door down Marcus still
screamed
in fact I was certain he didn't take a
breath I stood back unbeknownst as to
how close he was to the door before
booting it as hard as I could it swung
open immediately bits of wood spewing
here and there as the door smacked
against the adjacent wall
Marcus was sitting there pointing at the
window again as I stormed in half
expecting to see an intruder but there
was nothing just the blackness of the
window my own reflection cast in a vague
outline courtesy of the moonlight Marcus
I started towards him before stopping
short he looked up with his bulbous head
both of his dead eyes wet with tears
tears a father should have no qualms
wiping away he was drooling at the mouth
but at least the screaming had subsided
as he slowly receded back against the
headboard Marcus it was just a dream I
said in what I hoped was reminiscent of
what ADA had said earlier but Marcus
didn't look convinced and for once I
didn't blame him
sure duh he whispered in between snivels
I assumed dar meant dad but I wasn't
sure
maybe Marcus wasn't sure either it's so
caisson I said as I touched his hand for
perhaps the first time since his
diagnosis there's nothing to be sorry
for
but you hate thee he said perhaps the
only coherent words I'd ever heard him
say time froze then as I stood staring
down at my son a term I'd use loosely as
a result of his condition I'd always
thought he was too dumb to pick up on my
disdain I try to hide it at first but as
the years went on I couldn't hide it the
way I once did when I looked up my son I
saw a freak and I was far more ashamed
of him than I was at myself for feeling
that way
I I don't hate you was all I could
muster and I thought maybe he'd smile
again in that awfully giddy way whenever
a dirtay called his neck but I was wrong
he didn't smile he just looked at me
like a wounded animal tears in his
misshapen eyes and full of hurt shameful
as it sounds I was thankful when I heard
that sickly growl again it came from the
window and set Marcus off into a string
of hysterical shrieks I hid the lights
on in the room and that's when I saw it
in the window a pale figure that stood
at least six feet tall it stood there
for the briefest of moments so brief I
wasn't sure what I had seen it appeared
to have translucent fur as it's carpet
off like a peeping tom
disappearing into the darkness was that
the creature we'd been trying to
identify earlier today I had to know for
sure
Dogo Marcus must have known what I was
thinking and went to reach for me but I
managed to maneuver out of his reach and
despite his cries I didn't look back as
I stormed into the living room to
retrieve my rifle a part of me wishes I
stayed of Marcus then been a proper dad
and seen him off to sleep at the very
least but I wasn't a proper dad ever I
[Music]
grabbed the rifle in my hands only to
find Aaron sitting in the living room a
glass of scotch in one hand and his
phone in the other no doubt he was
stalking his ex-wife again drowning his
sorrows as he downvoted every one of her
photos particularly the ones with her
and her new boyfriend we didn't say
anything to each other but merely
acknowledged each other like we thought
the other one was weird
me and my gun and him and his unhealthy
habit the cries of Marcus were drowned
out as I grabbed a torch and strode into
the night I was hardly well-dressed to
brave the cold and while my robe and
slippers served well against the
bathroom chill they did nothing against
the unforgiving whips of icy air outside
I should have gone back to get my boots
and coat but I was already moving out of
my own
burning curiosity to see this creature
for myself that and I didn't want to
deal with Marcus didn't want to face the
boy I'd been crushing for so long I
stepped off the garden patio pushing
further into the dark listening
carefully for the sound of the creature
its footprints were everywhere large
wolf like prints that were heavy set and
fresh the torch danced in my hand and I
realized though I was shivering I had to
have been no more than thirty feet from
the house I couldn't turn back now I
wouldn't turn back I thought I'd heard a
snarling in the dark by an old tree in
the garden but when I flashed my torch
over there there was only an owl staring
down at me looking mighty peeved the
sound of my own breath was louder than
usual and missed the smoke billowed out
from my mouth I clutched the rifle tight
as I scanned the Willows scanned the
pond scanned the rocks in the corner and
the broken fence on the left-hand side
it seemed like the intruder had fled the
scene or so I thought a branch snapped
to my right and I spun finding the
creature immediately with my flashlight
but it was no hideous murderous looking
monster I was certain it wasn't even the
same shape as the thing I had seen in
the window a common lone wolf sitting
patiently in the darkness watching me
with the most focused set of yellow eyes
I'd ever seen I considered firing a shot
to scare it away as though Silas it
seemed a wolf is still a wolf after all
but before I could pull the trigger the
wolf scuttled off into the shrubbery the
COO of the owl droned out above me and
that was left in that chilly wintry
night shivering like a madman in my
slippers I felt more than a little
foolish and suddenly I became very aware
of the rifle cradled in my hands the
surge of adrenaline I'd felt was seeping
out of me like beer from a broken bottle
and that was left deflated at the
realization the screaming boy was still
in his room waiting for me I took a few
steps back searching the darkness for
any sign of the creature
hoping for any sign that it was still
out there anything to stop me having to
face my child and the overwhelming guilt
but I could feel the chill in my bones
now and that alone had me jogging back
to the house albeit reluctantly Marcus
had stopped screaming I assumed that ADA
had gotten up and taking care of him as
I made my way through the lounge
Aaron was still sitting there on his
cell phone furiously swiping and one of
those dating apps with a grim smirk on
his face if I was a better man I might
have shown him some sympathy but who was
I kidding
I couldn't even love my own son I
climbed up the stairs to Marcus's room
half expecting to see ADA with him
cradling him back to sleep oddly enough
his duvet looked like it had been flown
to the floor I entered cautiously but
Marcus wasn't there I even took a peek
under the bed but he was nowhere to be
seen
great I guess he's in my bed then ADA
had always been too accommodating of the
boy I stumbled into my room only to find
the lights are on and to my surprise one
half of the duvet was hanging messily
off the bed neither my wife nor son were
there where I expected them to be ADA I
called out as if there was somewhere she
could hide it was then I noticed the
dresser had been moved into a weird
angle the cosmetic items and cream she
used it all toppled over nail varnishes
cotton pads and mascara all scattered
around the dresser as I approached there
looked to be nail scratchings on the
floor for long grooves that I didn't
remember being there the night before
the grooves ran across the floor all the
way to the open window were a net
curtain billow gently in the wind why
the window was even open at all was a
mystery to me
I stormed over with the intention of
shutting it but that was when I saw
movement in the street below
I nearly did a double tank I didn't
believe what I was seeing my mouth went
dry my eyes widening with horror and all
of a sudden I was short of breath the
creature stood at least six feet tall
with a ghostly gray skin tugging its
legs were stalk like bony and envelops
her the thinnest of hair it had a
hunchback a large carapace of bone and
sickly sinew its arms could have been as
long as its legs perhaps longer
they were black as far as I could tell
with giant hands I could likely fit
around the bonus of a car it moved
quickly through the street making a
throaty grunting sound as it scattered
this way in that under each of its arms
had held a body on the right was Marcos
eyes closed and sleeping as peaceful as
could be in the left was Aida her eyes
wide and desperate as she looked at me
Hey I shouted at the creature put them
down but the creature didn't stop in
fact it didn't even look at me for all I
knew it hadn't even heard me I got to
see my wife's face one last time as she
mouthed something to me her green eyes
streaming with tears then she faded
right before my eyes along with the
creature and my son I didn't move
straight away a part of me was trying to
put together everything I'd just seen
was it all a dream was this just some
deep lucid sort of dream
I tried snapping myself but to my horror
I didn't wake my hands began to shake
and all of a sudden I couldn't remember
where I put the rifle I couldn't get
control of my breathing as I heaved and
half to short bursts of air choking on
my own saliva and clutching at my
tightening chest the creature had my
family I kept repeating the same line in
my head over and over again as if it
would make it more tangible but every
time it was just more ambiguous
the creature had my family all I could
do was grab the edge of the windowsill
was tightly as I could
debating as to whether calling the
police was the best move to make but
then what would I even say um yeah so
there's this monster thing outside my
house that I think may be responsible
for killing all those people when
animals from earlier and they'd also
just kidnapped my wife and son they'd
probably just throw me in a padded cell
with a straitjacket the creature had my
family and I had no idea what my next
move was until the native flashed into
my mind be careful friend he had said
the Beast does not tread without a
reason maybe I should have just gone to
the police told them everything and just
been done with it it was always going to
look suspicious was it not a man's wife
and son go missing and everyone usually
turns to the husband the spark of Ada
wasn't that bright anymore and I'd never
taken to Marcus given his condition but
I wish no ill upon them I didn't want
them dead quite the opposite
even now with their absence my heart
swelled something painful i darted
downstairs in a frenzy got my boots on
and wrapped up in my coat no the police
wouldn't understand such things but the
natives seemed to have some knowledge
and all this Aaron watched me stalk
about the lounge grabbing my keys my
wallet my phone and triple checking my
pockets
pretty soon though his eyes were drawn
to something far more foreboding the
rifle lay within his reach and for the
first time in a long time
I saw fire in his eyes he licked his
lips at the sight of it his mouth slowly
peeling apart in amazement
like he'd just laid eyes on a pair of
breasts for the first time I snatched
the rifle out of his reach and watched
the light die in his eyes I was I was
just looking at it he said of a star on
his star I was
did you see anything come in here I
ignored him while I was outside did you
see anything abnormal he stared back at
me with his milky and tired eyes with
nothing to say except for no something
has taken a dura Marcus I told him
trying to keep the panic out of my voice
I need to go to the reserve Erin
straightened in his seat what do you
mean something has taken them on they
upstairs know it sir I was going to
explain but it all sounded too crazy to
repeat what I'd seen what could Erin do
anyway
he barely seemed burdened by the fact
his sister and nephew had gone missing
in fact he seemed more than content just
to sit there on his phone just wait here
I told him a made my way out to the car
the moon sat timidly in the black sky
perhaps the only source of light except
for my high beams as I poured into the
reserve I looked over to the passenger
seat where the rifle was sitting and
snatched it up checking the safety was
off and checking if I filled it with
bullets admittedly I'd done this for the
12th time with my shaking hands but
could you blame me I saw no signs of the
natives no signs of anyone in this
remote grassland most of them are
probably comfy in their homes at this
time maybe some of them even live the
Nina city and only came out to hound
investigations like ours the yellow
police tape was torn and whit about like
a ribbon caught in a fan I could still
see patches of land strewn with bones
and guts that we'd left behind from the
massacre and the crisscross and of
deep-set tire tracks in the mud from all
our vehicles but there was no sign of
the natives just a pitter-patter of rain
on the windshield I let my head hit the
steering wheel there was nothing left
but to go to the police I started
theorizing what the best story wants
surely I can tell them a monster like
the one I'd seen had taken my family
from right under my nose I would have
been better off just telling them I done
away with them myself maybe I could just
report them missing tell the feds my
wife and son was simply abducted in the
night and I was none the wiser but then
what about Erin that pathetic worm of a
man flashed before my eyes and I
imagined him blabbering his mouth about
me storming off outside of a gun
disappearing into the night and acting
all strange no the police would never
buy my story but they would never buy
the truth either
[ __ ] I punched a steering wheel in
frustration as the rain came down harder
[ __ ] a punch it again this time hitting
the horn [ __ ] [ __ ] I struck it again
harder and harder as the rain drilled
against the car flooding the windscreen
I was openly screaming now hammering my
arms against the dashboard striking
anything in a blind pointless fury
sinking further and further into a wild
tantrum I couldn't control there was a
flash of light that had my heart skip a
beat and then a terrifying boom Thunder
shook the entire reserve the army of
trees ahead of me was shuffled like
cards in a deck
barks bent and leaves and branches
tangled of one another in a furious
commotion the wind howled long after the
explosion and i sat there cowering in my
car looking up at the night sky ablaze
with blue streaks of lightning
I was about to reverse and drive away
I had no destination in mind but I knew
I had to get out of there I wish I'd
gotten into reverse gear faster wish I
looked back and given the gas to touch
it needed to get the car going but
instead I looked straight ahead as the
windscreen wipers swiped back and forth
and there ahead of me stood a figure he
had his hands raised though in his left
he had a flashlight how I hadn't seen
him until now was a mystery he was
wearing a long green coat and stood at
least 6 foot tall as he lumbered his way
over I locked the doors he moved to my
side of the via
his haut blew off his head revealing his
weather-beaten face his dark hair tied
in a ponytail by a couple of colorful
ribbons his eyes were dead like before
his mouth twisted in a grim sorrowful
way I lowered my window a crack so you
have returned a friend the native spoke
but his voice seemed to carry over the
howl of the wind the rain pummeled him
but he showed no sign of any discomfort
the creature I shouted over the wind
where do I find it the native smirks you
do not find it it finds you cut the [ __ ]
I roared just tell me where it is he
didn't say anything for a moment but his
smirk was there his eyes once so dead
anymore but while widening with bitter
amusement you laughed at me he said you
and your fat friend laughed at me and
now you have come to seek my counsel
please I deflated just tell me where it
is and man and I'll pay you pay me he
seemed genuinely confused money I told
him as I reached into my wallet there
had to be nearly a hundred bucks then I
took fifty lowered the window even more
and handed it to him he looked at it
like I just handed him my own [ __ ] I do
not want money he shook his head then
have more money I upped the ante and
added another note here I don't want
money he said again yes you do I was in
hysterics
I threw the money at him and then I
threw the entire wallet I pulled the
keys out of the ignition and tossed them
at his face I even reached back and
grabbed a pack of
Oh chips and toss them at him too I
would have given him the coat around my
shoulders if he hadn't stopped me why
are you here friend i clenched my fist I
was shaking something chronic I couldn't
look at the native anymore I just sat
there staring at the dashboard of my car
unsure as to what was even real anymore
the native didn't prompt me for an
answer he just stood there patiently in
the rain what must have been five
minutes
his eyes fixed on me it has my firmly I
eventually said you will write about the
footprints I saw it with my own eyes saw
it scoop up my family and disappear into
the air hmm the native grunted like he'd
already deduced as much you best come
with me friend come with you I said
aghast where can't explain he said and
pointed into the woods where the trees
were still being bullied by the wind but
I will take you there perhaps it is not
too late to stop the Wendigo wendi-go I
shook my head what the hell is that the
less you know friend the better now
let's go there's not much time then get
in I unlocked the doors no cars he does
not like things of the modern world you
want us to walk in this weather I barked
as if he was mad and who is he the
native didn't answer me he simply
glanced into the passenger seat and said
rather poignant ly leave the car before
he started walking away then he muttered
but bring the gun we walked for what
felt like miles through the muddy
freezing punishing woods the native
stomped through the land as simply as I
might have walked on a sidewalk
me I was stumbling about like a [ __ ]
at the edge of a shoreline tackled by
the tide and shrimps by the pebbles now
and again lightning flashed and white
light streaked through the wood flooding
the area and taking my breath away the
native didn't show any signs are being
bothered by the storm
in fact I swear I heard him charcoal at
one point we had to climb a steep
incline spread with treacherous mud and
a carpet of scattered leaves I had to
use the gun as a crutch and even then I
nearly toppled backwards the mud soaked
through my boots and I could feel the
cold moisture infiltrating my socks
settling between my toes here the native
said and swept his arms slowly out
before him to my surprise a lone red
teepee sat in its own space flanked by
fallen trees and stationed perfectly
below what seemed to be a beam of
moonlight coloured smoke billowed around
the teepee blues and pinks misting in
and between each other the area around
the teepee looked untouched by the rain
a patch no bigger than a few strides and
drier than it ought to have been
I looked up half expecting to see a
shelter of some kind
perhaps a makeshift Shield of leaves
there was nothing but the black sky in
the shy moon poking out from the smokey
clouds the rain still fell but the
droplets didn't dampen the sand colored
dirt around the TV the flaps around the
tepee weren't billowing in the wind
either but merely swaying gently to
reveal the darkness within come the
native told me the Shaymin awaits
Shaymin I sounded off to make sure I'd
heard correctly Shaymin the native
confirmed be sure to greet him as such
he wasn't quite what I was expecting
then again I wasn't sure what to expect
a fat man sat cross-legged on the floor
of the teepee eyes closed and a short
grin on his face the same colored smoke
was puffed around the room with it came
the profound smell of honey and jasmine
it made me queasy the man before us
seemed like he had no idea we were there
his stomach was tattooed with white ink
and though there was a storm outside he
sat mostly naked except for the
ceremonial skirty war there were
feathers in his hair
bangles around his arms and a
scary-looking knife by his belt that had
me touching the gun tight announce
yourself the native launched me I looked
at him in the way I might have looked at
a friend egging me on to talk to a girl
at a bar but at least I knew what I was
getting from a girl at a bar probably a
weird look in a cold-shoulder
this guy this guy hadn't even opened his
eyes I stammered hello Shaymin Shaymin
is always snapped open the native took a
long step back and I had half a mind to
join him what do you mean Shaymin the
fat man barked at me both his eyes wide
and full of venom I managed to point to
the native he told me that you were bald
the fat man histor the native stop
telling people I'm a shame and it gives
them the wrong impression I am a man of
Medicine
of course the native replied barely able
to keep the laughter out of his voice I
would have said something if I wasn't
entirely confused as to where I was and
what was going on outside ER the
medicine man addressed me why have you
come to this place my I look back at the
native for some sort of assistance my
family were taken by by the monster
monster the medicine man rubbed his
Chin's be more specific you mean there
are others out there many hide in the
shadows of our world
he said with an all-knowing grin others
in plain sight he speaks of the Wendigo
the native step forward and seemed to
have gotten the giggles out of his
system
it has taken his family he comes here to
seek its location so that he may earn
them back many men have gone to battle
with a Wendigo spirit I know of only one
who succeeded though in the end it did
not matter what the hell is it I asked
the medicine man took a moment to flick
a bit of dirt from his teeth it is a
spirit of insatiable greed and hunger it
lives to consume the flesh of the living
the birds that deer the household pet
you me none of us are except from its
appetite I couldn't believe what I was
hearing but I'd seen it had I not I'd
seen the Wendigo right outside my house
skittering down the road of my wife and
child in its arms how does a thing like
this even exist
I challenged him many things of this
nature exist you do not see it because
your eyes are not open until it is upon
you do not blame yourself you are merely
a product of your father's you ask me
how something of this nature can exist
how can it not in this world the world
is full of greed war savageries
injustice and bloodshed the
materialization of evil is therefore
only certain I didn't much care for his
answer to be honest none of what he
really said sunk in until after it had
all been done he sat there all pompous
and wise his fat cheeks swelling with
triumph like he defeated the Wendigo
himself of the lecture he'd given me we
will have to conduct the procession the
medicine man spoke at last sit what
sit the medicine man hissed for some
reason I did as he said and sat right
before him the native move silently
beside me and took to his knees his eyes
closed and his head bowed low I wondered
whether I had to do the same but then
the medicine man began to chant
something to me it sounded like a long
creaking door all of a sudden his hands
began to move before his face in a
trance-like fashion I couldn't explain
why I didn't just grab the gun and head
out then and there but where would I
have gone so instead i sat there
transfixed by his tattoos which were now
lighting up like a Christmas tree I try
to move but I was stuck my legs weren't
responding my arms were heavy and when I
try to speak no words came out I managed
to Crane my head at the native only to
find his head moving slowly back and
forth seemingly bobbing to music only he
could hear my eyes grew heavy I'm pretty
sure the aromatic smoke was responsible
I wrestled against it but in the end my
eyes surrendered and I was dreaming
there's no way that dream could have
lasted that any longer than 30 seconds
the native would try and tell me it had
been hours but I didn't buy it I loved
all the crazy things I had seen that
night that's what I chose not to believe
I know crazy the dream had been running
through the woods and somehow I knew
where the Wendigo was I knew where Ada
and Marcus were and were rifle in hand I
was charging towards it I wasn't scared
either
but merely charged with a certain
electricity that had me storming forth
more like a Marine and not a wildlife
specialist it was an intoxicating
feeling a high I hadn't felt before I
felt invincible unstoppable
perhaps even godlike I felt like I could
crush the world in my palm I could do
anything in that moment I was charging
through the trees like a warrior juiced
up on cocaine I set my sights on the
Wendigos ghastly hide and lifted the gun
my eyes snapped open easy now the
medicine man said calmly before me take
a moment to gather your bearings
outsider I blinked hard the feeling I'd
felt was still there coursing through my
veins but it was fleeting and with it
came that dreadful anticipation of
returning to normal that same feeling
when you realize your sobering up I was
falling from my high in the ground was
rushing to meet me now you know where
the wendi-go is the medicine man placed
his hands on my shoulders I've blessed
you with an enchantment but you should
know that it won't last long and if you
don't listen to me that I shrugged him
off and hurried to my feet I knew
whether Wendigo was I knew where my
family were I'd wasted enough time here
I brush past the native and snatched up
the gun wait friend we have not finished
the ritual if you leave now then I know
where it is I snapped I'm going to kill
it you should really let me finish the
second blessing the medicine man advised
to leave now is too I didn't listen
I still wonder whether it would have
been any different if I'd stuck around
to get the second blessing I'd like to
think it wouldn't have made much of a
difference but damn it I still wonder I
try not to blame myself I still felt
like a God as I stormed out of the tepee
and into the rain I was so cocky right
then I almost tossed the gun to one side
I'd beat the creature to death with my
bare hand
but like I said that high was fading
fast and before long the cold rain had
me sobering up to my senses and the cold
wind reinstated the fear I should have
felt all along I found myself glancing
back at the TV contemplating whether to
go back for the second blessing or maybe
even just a bit of advice my heroic run
was short-lived pretty soon I'd gone
from leaping like Tarzan across trees
and through narrow confines to a
geriatric who had a lover failed the
floor
I couldn't keep to my feet my damn legs
were shaking and not because of the cold
to be honest I didn't feel the cold of
all the adrenaline pumping through me I
held the rifle close like a lover closer
than I'd ever held a de closer than I'd
ever held Markus that was for sure the
trees were black this deep into the
woods black like ink and horrifyingly
leafless giving way to the swirling
darkness of the night sky above each
tree was like a disfigured hand
thrusting out of the mud and the worst
thing about them was they provided no
cover from the eyes of the wendi-go
this whole time I'd come in with a
mindset of pouncing on an unaware but
now it was me looking over my shoulder I
had as much chance of seeing it as it
did see me my boots crunch the leaves it
was impossible to creep around every
movement had the fabrics of my clothing
announcing my presence I kept the
torchlight low hoping it wasn't serving
as a beacon to the Wendigo that I was
lurking in its domain my breath was
quickening I tried to breathe only
through my nose but I felt suffocated
the air was thicker here so thick it was
almost crushing the wind had calmed down
and the rain had become nothing more
than a drizzle but something told me
that the real storm was only just
beginning
it wasn't long before I could smell it
I didn't know what a Wendigo smelled
like but when I smelled that night
sometimes you just know it smelled foul
a combination of vomit and [ __ ]
permeated the already thick air and had
me gagging and wheezing I pressed on
barely able to stop myself contributing
my own sick to the stench my eyes were
watering my bladder was full
my back hurt I was losing sight of what
my mission even was here or how I'd even
hope to achieve it
I remember the medicine man had said he
had known of one man who'd successfully
defeated a Wendigo spirit but in the end
it hadn't mattered it made me wonder
what that guy had done and why his
efforts were so futile in the end surely
I wouldn't be the same no I'd make sure
hey someone whispered in a dark voice
who's there I lifted the gun and spun
around I circled around at least eight
or nine times scanning everything from
the brittle blackened trees to the
uneven rolls of dirt I didn't even know
which direction it came from I pressed
on my mouth was dry my nose was running
but I couldn't stop because I was
holding the rifle like my life depended
on it came the voice again this time I
didn't react it sent chills down my
spine and had me twitching with fear I
knew I'd heard it further ahead this
time further onwards amongst a cluster
of broken bits of log behind a mound of
dirt
it said and like a fool I obliged
I stood at the mound of dirt but the
only thing I could focus on was that
smell that smell of guts and blood and
[ __ ] I swear to you I can still smell it
now that sweating sickly sacrilegious
smell of death I could feel it in the
back of my throat as I forced myself to
walk around the mound of dirt I
struggled to move around the logs cut up
my legs on sharp branches and earned
myself enough splinters gone was the
element of surprise
and if the wendigo didn't hear me
cursing the laws it would have heard me
coughing up that thick fusty smell I
clutched the gun as I inch further
around the mountain free of the logs at
last I caught a glimpse of its elbow as
it dug its claw into something I prayed
it wasn't ADA the sound of its growling
and panting was suddenly apparent it
sounded like a starve dog lips smacking
and teeth carving into something I held
my breath if the Wendigo had my wife I'd
unload the whole [ __ ] chamber into
its head and bash its ghostly skull into
tiny pieces but to my relief as I drew
nearer it wasn't the Wendigo devouring
my wife's flesh that relief however
quickly turned to horror when ADA looked
at me
her mouth bloody is she absently Nord
away at the corpse on the floor
no it wasn't the wendi-go feasting on my
wife it was my wife feasting on my son I
lowered the gun I didn't know what I was
seeing how could I ada sat atop of
Marcus whose bulbous head was strewn a
few feet from his body one of his eyes
was missing the other staring at me in
that gormless languid way it always
looked at me weird he was a weird kid
his nose had been punched in his lips
seemingly ripped off his face exposing
his crooked bloody teeth damn kid almost
looked like he was smiling at me in a
horribly petrifying way funny how I
could hardly even look at him when he
was alive but now that his head was off
his shoulders and his face had been
brutally devoured I couldn't look away a
de Bie stammered she grunted mouth half
full of more of Marcus's flesh she was
pulling pieces of him like she was
dipping into a bag of chimps her nails
dug deep into his chest his arms his
legs just about anywhere she could reach
she tore his body into pieces of no
effort blood spraying everywhere as she
stuffed her mouth with more meat Aida
for Christ's sake stop I found my voice
but I didn't find my feet if I did I
might have bolted the other way she
glanced over her shoulder at me it
wasn't just the blood around her mouth
that had me shaking and was her eyes
those green eyes had once fallen for
when our gray and swirling she stared
nothing short of death into me she took
one last chunk out of Marcus sucked the
flesh right off the bone and tossed it
behind her when she stood up ada
I warned her stay there I didn't finish
my sentence
what could I even say she started pacing
towards me her hands dripping with the
blood of our son her gown was soaked
with red and she moved rigidly
her head hanging loosely to the side ada
I tried again please her eyes are fixed
on me a crazed sort of smile painted its
way onto her face and then that's when I
saw the creature I'd seen in the street
was there hovering above her
it had to have been a split second but
I'd committed the Windigo to memory its
grin mirrored the smile of my wife its
face so dark I couldn't see any of the
other features it's long arms or guiding
ADA nudging her forward towards me get
away from her
I fired into the air birds scattered
from the trees and the wild set of hoots
went out into the air but it did nothing
to stop the Wendigo spirit all my
approaching wife ADA she was but a mere
ten paces away from me now post enough
to dive at me if she really wanted to
sink her teeth into me ada please it was
all I could think to say she growled
into the air like a wild savage the
veins in her neck pulsing as she
screamed she barreled in my direction
heedless of my pleas her bloody nail was
outstretched towards me so I shot her
the bullet went through her neck and she
stumbled backwards stunned blood
streamed out of the hole the bullet had
made and I expected her to drop right
there and then but she didn't she
grunted and then growled and then she
was laughing
not her laughter though but the Wendigos
awful deep laughter that had me
clenching at everything I had she came
at me again but this time I hesitated
I started aiming at parts of her body I
said not harm her stupid I know I'd
already shot her in the throat and now I
was aiming at her leg so that she might
somehow survive all of this and we could
just go home and figure this all out all
we had to do was get her in the shower
wash off the blood and glue Marcus's
head back on we could save this I could
save this
I shot her in the thigh and she went
down stumbling through the dirt she
didn't stay down long though she crawled
her way towards me and I shot her again
this time in the shoulder stay down
I cried in frustration she came at me
again and I fired into her chest I shot
two more into her stomach and again in
her neck I emptied the entire chamber
into her before I heard the distinct
clicking of the gun that signaled I was
out of ammo
as well as out of options just stop I
begged her I was sobbing like a child I
felt a one knee in hope that there was a
shred of her left just an ounce of the
woman I loved just so she could come to
her senses now came that Wendigos reply
as Aida lunged at me one last time stop
I roared and swung the gun at her face I
saw a tooth go flying out of her mouth
as her entire head whipped around she
slipped in the muck and went down hard
but it wasn't long before the Wendigo
was laughing again and either was
readying to pounce again stop I cried
again as I battered her with a gun
slamming the Bott of the weapon down
against her skull stop I shouted as the
gun went flying from my hands and I
started throwing my fists I screamed at
her as my fist drilled into her forehead
into her eyes into her cheeks smashing
in her mouth her nose and every inch of
her face I screamed as loud as I could
as my fists came thundering down upon
her with each strike the Wendigo was
laughing less and less just [ __ ] stop
I cried as I landed the last punch I
could muster and then collapsed on top
of her gasping for breath I couldn't
feel my hands I tried to find the next
move but it never came
I must have laid there for hours soaking
in my wife's blood unable to move my
face out of the puddle that now pulled
around it the woods were silent
it was the most silence I'd ever heard
in my life the state of nothingness
until the weakest sound came out of her
mouth she haze a jolted upwards and
looked down at the beat and pulp of
flesh and choked her eyes are moving for
just a moment I would spend the next
hour shaking her moving her shouting at
her but my wife was dead I'd beaten her
to death
I could feel Marcus as I fixed on me but
I didn't look back at his mangled face
why start now
I found the moon instead and watched as
it grew further and further obscured by
the churning clouds until it was
swallowed up for good and that was the
last time I saw it hurried footsteps
came from behind
a part of me would have reached for the
gun but I didn't care it was probably
the cops anyway the idea to avoid being
accused of my wife's murder sure worked
out didn't it I was about to lift my
hands and place them on my head but the
voice that followed didn't belong to the
police
[ __ ] the native whispered friend are you
ok I just looked at him vacantly I think
I'd bit on my tongue and it made it more
difficult to answer him anyway he knelt
down with me his hands cupped around my
face as he stared earnestly into my eyes
I had hoped maybe the second blessing
might have avoided this no I am truly
sorry yeah I winced come with me friend
I can help you through this he told me I
know what it's like to have everything I
knocked his hand away how how could you
possibly know
I know the native side as he took my
hand I know what the medicine man said
was true there was another man who
defeated the Wendigo
but it didn't matter in the end for him
he spoke like he was in pain now either
I was still fueled from the encounter or
just too dense together the meaning of
his words so what what does it have to
do and then I realized he nodded slowly
like you I came searching when it took
my family like you I found them and like
you I was too late oh I whispered and we
sat there in silence after that just
staring up at the sky waiting for the
moon to come back but it never did
I looked at the tormenter opposite me as
I relished in his moment Harry struggled
to process the events I'd explained his
glasses were covered in mist but he
didn't take them off to wipe them down
as he usually did what happened to the
native he asked me flipping a page on
his pad and scribbling more [ __ ] down
hell if I know and that was the truth by
the time we'd made it back to the
reserve the police had that place
flooded of guns pointed at me seems like
someone may have tipped them off about
Marcus's and ADA's mysterious
disappearance as well as my own you
wouldn't happen to know anything about
that would you
Aaron mr. Mason I think you would do
well to remember that I am the one
asking the questions
why is that I challenged I smelt blood
in the water
I could see my tormentor my
good-for-nothing therapist of a brother
in law squirming in his seat you were
there that night carrying out your pervy
antics on your phone you know there's
more than meets the eye here why don't
you just tell them and then we can mr.
Mason he stopped me if you continue down
this path you will never be free of this
asylum confess to what you have done and
we can move on to the next stage of your
therapy it was the [ __ ] Wendigo I
barked go find the natives ask them we
cannot find these natives or the reserve
you speak of because they do not exist
Aaron replied a twitch of annoyance in
his face mr. Mason you have fabricated
this entire story as a way of dealing
with your grief it's okay you are an
unwell man
so are you you freak i hissed at him
what's it like knowing your ex-wife is a
dirty [ __ ] she even got your house I
laughed at him I'm all you've got left
you prick that's why you took this job
when they offered it to you because I'm
the only thing that reminds you of what
you once had curious how your wife's
records have no mention of her brother
who is Aaron mr. Mason
don't play games with me you and I know
that you conveniently misplaced these
records and no one would ask questions
you're not falling anyone it appears we
are done for today I will see you in the
morning mr. Mason he declared and
hurried out of the door I was left in
the same position as I always was
staring down at my hands as I ran my
fingers over each knuckle every one of
them stained with blood her blood I sat
back and waited for the strong men to
come in and unshackle me from my
confines I wondered whether they'd talk
to me this time or whether they just
ignore me of those cold emotionless eyes
maybe I'd open up a joke this time
pretty soon my thoughts drifted the way
they always did and I found myself
trying to picture my beautiful ADA's
face but all I could see was blood